changer de caisse et de psa lavely
patriarcat troupeau d'éléphants devant
lui et d'or où sa mémoire nous
attendions changé à wil à la rtbf est
encore trois minutes en rien aux yeux
regarde le danger marqué 7 le pousse à
le voir comme ça à ton regard de
l'arrivée la jambe là quand même
l'énergie pas mais remonte au 4
suppléants l'art d'éléphants la
tendresse et dessus dans les arbres
devant toi dans les salles de vente a vu
dans les orp le vent du vent c'est cela
qui faillit cherchant dessus lambalamba
qui ira son plan était bien au-dessus du
vide et on plante suffit les tons plan
vertical de supporteurs
voilà en vertical dessus ça va être au
vu des cassettes dessus passer au dessus
kartika sari trou là dessus sans un
sérieux ça y est ils sont nerveux la
deuxième attaque
moi je vois tout louvre un nom c'est bon
pour nos fenêtres parce que pour mieux
disait c'est l'impression qui bouge qui
secoue le mont vernon en plus c'est bien
avant l'heure de jeu bien sa voix la
super duke en charge les genres et quand
on regarde les hors jeu super verticale
des maisons et véhicules
shadows va le faire bien sûr les ondes
c'est beau ça peut faire une belle offre
de l'effluent sepric ific
voilà qui est vraiment vraiment en
profil bas ces polars garde un regard
les orques sont magnifiques
c'est très beau sac saison contre la
superbe ferme ça suffit disposer d'un
armement y avait robert borden
championnat plein match en réanimant
rentrée d'entretien y aura pleins
partout il y aura encore beaucoup plus
pour en voir encore plein d'autres
beaucoup plus que prévu un prix les
troupeaux du long et si ça fait du chant
celui qui pendant les six années du
champ là où la victime en fait ça fait
partie du champ laissé sortir aux
caisses changer la cassette changer la
cassette c'est bon on n'a pas de
certitudes j'en attends attends je
braille dessus non non on les dit ça il
ya un groupe aux pauvres s'occupent au
bon voilà changer qu'à cet âge